of course not even a wardrobe
malfunction can stop cardi B from going
hard the rapper took the stage at the
Bonnaroo Music and Arts Festival on
Sunday night and told the audience about
a clothing mishap that caused her to
leave the stage for a bit cardi returned
after a few minutes and explained that
she ripped her outfit her solution Rock
a white bathrobe onstage after trading
her colorful costume for the fluffy robe
cardi led the audience through a ton of
her hits including I like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and be careful and at one point cardi
even pulled down the top of her robe
exposing a strapless nude bra
after recently canceling and postponing
a series of shows to recover from
liposuction surgery
the singer declared on Twitter that she
was hitting the gym to avoid ever having
to go under the knife again
she explained quote I've been working
out for the past two weeks cuz I ain't
getting surgery again let me tell you I
haven't got a headache ever since the
way that my body be swelling up when I
catch planes ish it's so scary did I be
freaking out days earlier cardi shared
this pic of her swollen feet on
Instagram to show the negative side
effects of her procedure she wrote quote
look how swollen my feet get every time
I take a plane imagine my body reasons
why doctors told me to chill on shows it
was important to me to share you know
what a lot of people was just like
egging me on to do it even though I was
going to do it because I really want to
explain to people how hard is the
process I feel like a lot of people look
at girls on Instagram and think like oh
they got they lipo done and it was so
easy and this is such a long hard
process it's almost like the same
process as after you give birth to a
baby and you seen your body change and
snap in your back is the same way but I
will talk later our body more
[Music]